[Musica]
il ponte c'è una connessione fra
l'immagine di un ponte che qualcosa che
quando attraversiamo ci porta da uno
scenario a un altro e l'idea di futuro
che qualcosa che quando arriva la ci
porta da un presente a un altro
conosciamo bene alcuni ponti io ad
esempio immagino che gli abitanti di
bastano conoscono bene in questo ponte e
quando conosciamo bene un ponte è
difficile che una volta attraversato ci
ritroviamo in un luogo in uno scenario
che ci sorprende ma alcune volte non
conosciamo il ponte e in questi casi può
capitare che attraversarlo significhi
ritrovarsi in uno scenario inaspettato
anche questo sembra vero del futuro
molto spesso il futuro è banale forse
addirittura non noioso in molti casi
sappiamo bene cosa capiterà domani a noi
ma alcune volte non è così è facile
trovare esempi se pensiamo agli ultimi
episodi nella nostra vita legati alla
pandemia sono sicuro che ciascuno di voi
avrà vissuto avrà dovuto cambiare i
propri progetti o addirittura cancellare
qualche evento che voleva fare ad
esempio questo un esempio molto
personale io a giugno devo sposarmi con
il mio compagno che di hong kong
dovevano starci a barcellona dove
viviamo ora voi immaginate di recuperare
tutti i documenti chiamare gente da più
o meno due continenti
non ci siamo ancora riusciti ora
se queste immagini del ponte è
un'immagine così buona del futuro se in
qualche senso una metafora completa del
futuro uno potrebbe chiedersi perché mai
e anche molto naturale pensare che il
futuro si possa cambiare
ora io penso che il futuro non si possa
cambiare e cercherò di spiegarvi perché
ma nel contempo penso anche che non sia
qualcosa di cui dobbiamo aver paura
dunque perché penso che il futuro non si
possa cambiare beh innanzitutto quando
noi diciamo che il futuro è cambiato
molto spesso quello che in effetti
stiamo dicendo è che la storia che
ricopre il ruolo del futuro non è quella
che ci aspettavamo che in certo senso ci
siamo sbagliati rispetto al futuro e in
questo senso quindi parlare di
cambiamento è semplicemente usare una
metafora
vi faccio un esempio per spiegarvi
esattamente perché è un esempio scrivere
un pochettino titubanti ma poi ha fatto
sorridere così tanto gli organizzatori
che mi hanno convinto a tenerlo un amica
sarah che cambia spesso al fidanzato e
sarà diciamo quello che si dice un tipo
cioè un uomo sulla trentina sportivo in
genere
l'altro giorno io e il mio compagno
invitiamo saracena e si presenta con un
uomo distinto sulla cinquantina non
particolarmente sportivo quando mi
ritrovo in cucina da solo con il mio
compagno di col mio compagno è visto il
fidanzato di sara è cambiato ovviamente
stavo facendo una battuta e quello che
stavo dicendo veramente è che la persona
che ricopre il ruolo del fidanzato di
sara aveva delle caratteristiche che non
ci aspettavamo ma se le cose stanno così
se questo è ciò che veramente stavo
dicendo parlando di cambiamento questo
senso metaforico perché non pensare la
stessa cosa anche del futuro perché non
pensare che quando diciamo anche il
futuro è cambiato quello che stiamo
dicendo in effetti è semplicemente che
ci sbaglia
abbiamo rispetto a quello che sarebbe
stato il futuro
qualcuno potrebbe obiettare che anche se
questo è vero c'è una differenza fra il
caso di nel caso in cui diciamo c'è una
differenza fra dire e pete futuro è
cambiato e noi abbiamo cambiato il
futuro magari cambiare il futuro non è
una cosa facile e questo lo si vede dal
fatto che molto spesso ci impegniamo per
poter cambiare il futuro non iniziamo
una lieta prendiamo un mutuo
facciamo un corso per imparare una
lingua straniera la roba dipingere sulla
ceramica e ovviamente sembrerebbe che
sarebbe difficile spiegare perché
facciamo tutte queste cose che ci
costano fatica spesso se non pensassimo
di poter cambiare il futuro
in fondo se i nostri successi sono già
nel futuro allora ci basta basta che ci
sediamo aspettiamo prima o poi
arriveranno se non sono già il futuro
invece potremo fare qualsiasi cosa ma
non arriveranno anche questa maniera di
pensare penso non sia corretta
il punto è che anche se il futuro non si
può cambiare
questo non vuol dire che non sia il
futuro non sia indeterminato in
filosofia contemporanea spesso si
raffigura l'idea di indeterminatezza in
termini di possibilità o alternative
future il futuro è indeterminato nel
senso che ci sono molte alternative
futura ce ne sono più di una e in questo
senso di un futuro è fondamentalmente
diverso dal passato che invece unico per
esempio io stamattina l'ho fatto
colazione al bar sono andato al bar
ordinato un caffè
l'ho bevuto l'ho pagato e poi sono
uscito se io guardo al passato dato
quest ora dal presente quello che vedo è
una linea che dove ogni evento è seguito
da uno solo 11 solo altro evento ma se
io dal presente guardo non solo al
passato ma anche al futuro quello che
vedo
tanto una linea piuttosto qualcosa come
un albero prendete ad esempio questo
presente allora io mi trovo qui davanti
a voi con le mani in avanti a questo
presente potrebbe essere seguito da un
futuro in cui io alzo la mano destra un
futuro in cui alza la mano sinistra
potete scommettere cosa succederà
facciamo così
alzo la mano sinistra in un certo senso
prima che il futuro arrivasse c'erano
due opzioni c'era giuliano che armano
l'abbraccio di braccio destro giuliano
che alza braccio sinistro
il futuro era composto ha due
alternative
in questo senso era indeterminato
ora qualcuno potrebbe dire appunto non
tu con le tue azioni lo hai cambiato lo
hai reso determinato sei passato da
qualcosa di indeterminato con due
opzioni ha determinato come il passato
soluzione ma anche questo non è
totalmente corretto ora in un certo
senso le due opzioni sono sì uguali
entrambe avrebbero potuto capitare ma di
fatto solo una è capitata solo solo
punto l'opzione braccio sinistro è
capitata
[Musica]
alcuni filosofi parlano del futuro
sulla base di queste considerazioni come
di una sottile linea rossa
l'idea è che per quanto dal punto di
vista del presente in futuro sia
costituito da molte alternative
il futuro sia alla fine una linea perché
perché il futuro appunto ce n'è solo uno
solo uno si realizzerà sia una linea che
rossa perché si distingue dalle altre ma
anche sottile sottile perché non è
fondamentalmente diversa dalle
alternative dalle altre alternative
tutte le altre alternative in
particolare segnano vedere quelle che
contengono le mie azioni saranno tali
per cui quello che ho fatto
se ho avuto successo di fatto non è
stato sufficiente quindi dal punto di
vista di questa metafisica del futuro di
questa idea di che cosa sia il futuro il
futuro è una serie di eventi che
coinvolge i miei tentativi i miei
successi ma ahimè talvolta anche i miei
fallimenti e in questo senso il futuro
non si può cambiare ma questo non vuol
dire che per quanto possibile il nostro
destino non sia nelle nostre mani
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]